The Joe Rogan experience,
let's take like just one small example
of how my belief system works about
this.
Uh,
there's this one thing called the
accumulation mindset.
I call it a,
I work online with people on fat loss
programs and when you really look at
their lifestyle,
their into the cumulation mode of just
buying an,
amassing all this stuff.
I've been in some people's homes where
the shelves are just littered with stuff
they never use or,
or don't need,
you know,
they,
they just have so much stuff.
The attic is full of stuff.
That garage is full of stuff,
but they keep buying more and more.
Adding,
adding,
adding.
Their bodies reflect this type of belief
system and for sure they're adding more
cells under their agent.
Just indulgent,
you know,
and then they find themselves over
eating,
eating more than their fair share of the
natural resources of the universe.
Taking more in A.
I mean it's just like this whole belief
system in accumulation like I need to
add,
I need to add is all subconscious.
Of course,
no one goes into it,
you know,
how much do you sleep?
Maybe now that I'm doing all this crazy
stuff,
three hours,
lot.
Wow.
What do you normally sleep if you
weren't doing this course?
If I'm lucky.
Wow.
Four hours.
Maybe we'll you're juiced up on nicotine
all.
No,
it has to do with.
I have to worry the editing,
like you know,
like I have to do the notes at night so
that they can edit during the day and
then I go in at night and then now like
with all these,
like with radio as you know,
like radio and all this stuff.
It's like there's a weird schedule to
all of that and then doing shows at
night because I never stopped doing
shows.
Right.
Of course.
But I meant like when you're not doing
this and you said five hours,
five hours maybe.
Is that because you're all juiced up
with nicotine?
All the time?
I think as I'm old and my prostate tells
me it's time to get up,
take a leak.
Five hours and you're good.
If I'm lucky,
you know,
get some palm palm juice.
Have you tried some of those pills that
help?
What is this Dr Oz.
It's like we were just watching heavy
metal and there's like a,
a Caribou carcass here.
It's like,
have you ever thought of like who gives
a shit?
It's part of getting old guys get used
to it,
get used to it.
Joe,
you're old enough to start now and not
have any.
Probably any problems from smoking.
You'll try it out for a year.
You would never have anybody who was an
athlete in their youth or like stole.
Is involved in athletics.
Like smoking is a.
no,
my cardio is very important to me.
Yeah,
yeah,
I understand that.
You know,
I'd never fuck around with that.
I do love like a,
you know,
smokers do like,
I'm just talking about like my dad and
his friends,
they would have amazing smoker
superpowers where it's like,
no,
they couldn't do anything but like if
there was something like,
you know,
hey,
I need your help.
What happened?
My car fell in a ditch and like they
would just like come out with a
cigarette in their mouth and like,
lift up.
I was like,
man,
that's so cool.
You know,
there's a diaper that they're selling
now.
Tony,
Tony Boucher,
for a lot of times a menu you fucking
get a little drippage is a Tampon word
the front of your diaper
because you're directly manpower and
they're trying to sell it as like a
normal thing.
Meanwhile,
this guy with this swollen,
inflated gut filled with undigested food
and feces that hasn't been pushed out
yet.
Fat that permeates all the different
layers of his skin and muscle left under
that.
I'm muscles.
They're all gone.
I'm here to throw you that my big game,
broken dixon leaking.
Trust me.
Just wear a Tampon.
Keep reading them.
Fucking meatball subs deletion.
Fuck
balls,
balls inside.
They got Monica got.
They got good to got the good peppers
they put on the top day society.
My mother,
God bless her,
she died of a heart attack at 51.
She weighed 300 pounds.
He's the guy driving the truck that
beep,
that fucking God had and got my fucking
pepper.
Got My meatballs.
I know when I walk my fat on my feet
spills over the outside of my sneakers.
I like that.
That looks like a little waterfall to
get into my heel lift.
When I stepped down,
just
rolls over.
I liked a lot because my fucking guns,
my gun sticking out.
My legs can't stay the way the back of
my head looks to the hot dog roll.
Look,
I like fat sausages that are growing out
of the base of my skull.
Just you look certainly makes you hungry
for the fucking the either the fucker in
source.
Each
look at my face.
You see a wrinkle in my face.
You see any spider remarks by my eyes?
Fuck no,
because the flesh is pushing out against
the skin all the time.
It's pulled tight.
It makes me look young and vibrant.
Look at my Chin's tight.
All of a diet.
Tell.
Tell a story about how,
how you wrote your training with our
Lawsky.
Oh,
after,
after training.
Where he's.
He goes,
come here.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
Andre Arlovski and I used to train
together Jackson's camp.
If I was getting ready for a fight this
over shoot almost four years ago,
the two fighters that I,
when I first got into the game that I
admired and loved,
we're Mirko Cro,
cop and Andre Arlovski,
my two very favorite.
That's who I wanted to be like.
So I walked into the gym and it was our
last skis first day at Jackson's too.
And uh,
you know,
when you see a guy on tv fighting all
the time,
then you run into me like,
damn,
all right.
So I see.
I'm like,
Oh shit,
there's under lawsky.
So then shopper last year in the ring,
a first day spine,
right,
fresh off the plane and we're sparring
with him.
So me and him are gone and it's a close
round.
He's a bad ass right?
And here we're going back and forth.
People would literally stop and watch
his spar with just these dog rounds back
and forth,
five rounds in a row.
Then later that night we grapple and
then,
uh,
the next morning I drink coffee every
morning,
right?
Drinking coffee,
not this horrible coffee breath,
breath smelled like pure coffees.
Shit breath right now.
You go up to Andre and he's not very
warm person at all.
Not at all.
Is that very bell Bruce Rush in where
it's going to take awhile to be his
friend.
I can tell and I'm trying to break these
barriers.
Fan.
I don't know.
Hey,
just wanna let you know man.
I got the coffee breath and he,
he didn't say a word to me the night
before training goes.
It's okay.
Much better than yesterday.
Yesterday.
Shit.
I go,
why?
He goes yesterday.
Breast smelled like shit.
Oh cool man.
Cool.
And then just went about our business.
That was really the only words he ever
said to me,
man.
And we trained together for for awhile.
It wasn't even like from it.
What about when you were kicking,
when you had your kick his body?
Yeah.
And then we'll get done training.
I've never done this.
He goes,
I'm trying to do my best Russian accent
it.
You guys are pretty much terrible.
Horrible,
right?
Sorry,
I'm not from Russia.
He goes,
uh,
he was put your hands on top of your
head like this.
And I'm like,
what are we doing?
And we just got done sparring.
I'm exhausted.
I put my hands up and he just goes,
braced herself and starts wailing at my
body with kicks punches whalen is this
make you tough?
My okay.
And I'm like,
oh,
I'll try and be tough though because
he's my hero.
I'm like,
oh,
okay.
Oh Wow.
And then he goes,
my turn,
you do it to me.
And I'm like,
Dooney,
no,
you hit like girl hit and I'm fucking
trying man.
I'm trying to hurt this guy.
Nothing.
And that was my experience with Andre
Arlovski.